every time there's a new call of duty
trailer it always looks a lot like a
call of duty trailer dramatic soldier
men and bombastic set pieces and slick
wartek and all that has become
synonymous with call of duty but this
advanced warfare trailer has me thinking
what about all those other games that
have totally done this stuff taking
inspiration from your predecessors is
par for the course in pretty much any
art form so where has sledgehammer
taking their inspiration from for Call
of Duty advanced warfare well straight
out of the gate we get a face full or
back full of Matt Damon in Elysium if
his black markets skull grafted suit
thing he could make him that badass
think of what Call of Duty's exosuit can
do to the trailers credit you don't have
to rely on your imagination for too long
fast forward and bam super jumps I am
super down with this just throw me a
nano suit and call me Alcatraz because
it's crisis to time you think we'll have
to route power to different abilities in
a similar way like if I want a super
jump do I have to tone down my mega
punch that's right I said mega punch
take that you know windshield having
truck see you later corporal drive guy
bullying cars as a time-honored
videogame tradition from the superheroic
smashes in prototype to the Martian
hammer times of red faction guerrilla
really helps you indulge those
pedestrian power fantasies when might
makes right and nothing powerfully
expresses the pure power of your power
suit like a poop poop up our thumbs up
our me two the 40th day fist bumps
anyone quick game of rock-paper-scissors
alright exosuit you're cool and all and
it's good to know we'll be able to
customize and upgrade you from mission
to Mission so is this hot warframe mask
one of the options idris elba is a space
ninja 1000 someone's been reading my
fanfiction alright what else you have in
this XO bag of tricks oh hey cloaking
good to see you or you know not totally
see you that's sort of mostly
see-through look reminds me of my old
pal master chief grabbing that shiny
translucent pyramid and going all
wibbly-wobbly now you see me now you
don't combat Evolved indeed but what
about those climbing gloves okay
spelunky is probably too far of a
stretch and mission impossible ghost
protocol is well pretty spot-on but not
actually a game Assassin's Creed maybe
infamous how those guys are just too
nimble this is more like black ops 2 but
without the cool rope swinging man
pendulum kind of thing eventually the
advanced warfare trailer takes the whole
power suit thing to an extreme with this
hulking beast right here channeling a
little bit of planetside 2 I mean a
minigun arm is cool but max suits can
rock friggin anti air cannons on the
right and the left damn so what about
the stuff that's not associated with
some sort of man suit I'm talking about
hoverbikes right here coming straight
out of Star Wars Galaxies snake it
through trees on the forest moon of
Endor may look a sight prettier than
negotiating the clogged freeways of
Nigeria but hovering ain't nothing wrong
with that you want to get a little more
airborne though and keep some drones
into the sky ghost recon future soldier
at least took it a little easier on your
back with lighter more reusable drones
they would scout and return to you but
uh I don't think this one's coming back
now towards the end things get a bit
dicey on the Golden Gate Bridge kind of
like they did during the anti climactic
final battle of homefront here's hoping
we actually get into San Francisco this
time and don't just get shafted with
some voiceover and a slow fade out and
oh my god I can't believe that campaign
was so short okay finally we got to talk
about the elephant in the room Kevin
Spacey a new face for video game
villainy hardly my friends just take a
look at 2006's Superman Returns
and you're going to wish you to never
return Oh Lex you're incorrigible so
yeah there's a lot going on in that
trailer and I'm sure we didn't catch all
of it did you spot any other
inspirations or do you have a better
reference for one of ours comments
people you know how this works see you
next time
you